so she's on her list of names who else
is on the list Joffrey
circe will defray Meryn Trant
Tywin Lannister the red woman beric
Dondarrion the Russell mayor Ilyn Payne
the mountain would you shut up I can't
sleep until I say the names the names of
every [ __ ] person in Westeros only
the ones I'm going to kill huh
hates us good a thing as any to keep a
person going better than most we come
across my brother maybe we can both
cross a name off a list
hey everybody is Charlie we need to talk
about Arya Starks list during season
eight in a special clay game ball theory
because they call a lot of their shots
earlier in the series and I believe that
they're going to be paying off a lot of
these setups during season eight
so of course Arya is gonna cross the
rest of the names off her list but some
of them are gonna be really big twist
paying off other Easter eggs that they
set up earlier in the series there's a
new book giveaway going on all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so here's
the rundown on aurea's list that clip
from season 4 episode 5 around the
campfire that's about as long as it ever
got it got really short because a lot of
those names were crossed off for her by
other characters she crossed off Walder
Frey at the beginning of season 7 when
she wore his face it was one of the
greatest ways to open that season Meryn
Trant she crossed off when she was in
Braavos at the end of season 5 Tywin
Lannister was crossed off by Tyrion who
killed him on the [ __ ] at the end of
season 4 just a couple of episodes after
she recited his name here and as of
season 7 Thoros of Myr died while they
were north of the wall with the
Brotherhood without banners to the army
of the Dead so couple big names already
off of her list at the beginning of
season 8 she took the Hound off of her
list during season 6 so there are only
five official names that are left on it
and I don't expect her to add any more
because we're marching towards the
finale there are only six episodes so
it's just like a slow gauntlet of people
that she carves her way through towards
the end in order it's still Cersei
Ilyn Payne the mountain beric Dondarrion
in Melisandre the
woman as she calls her but here's the
thing even though the order goes that
way I think that the order in which she
kills them is gonna change a little bit
just because of real life factors
involved in making the show and which
characters are more meaningful to the
audience and to her character so for
instance Ilyn Payne is really important
he's the person that executed Ned Stark
so of course it's very important for her
to cross his name off her list
but because the actor that plays Ilyn
Payne in real life had cancer related
health problems he hasn't been able to
be on the show for the past couple of
seasons he's just not as meaningful in
the minds of the audience without
getting a big reminder like oh yeah this
is Ilyn Payne he's the person that
killed Ned Stark of course we want him
dead so think about it this way the
King's Landing characters are all
probably at the top of the list just
structurally because she's at Winterfell
right now and there are a bunch of
characters headed to Winterfell because
of a big battle with the night king in
the war for the dawn so just think about
where and when these characters are all
coming into proximity to each other and
that's sort of how they're going to
progress through Arya's list so early
predictions this is how I think this
goes down at the beginning of the season
first she has the Gendry reunion sort of
continuing where they left off the of a
short moment addressing all the things
that they said to each other the last
time they were together about Arya
confessing all of her feelings to Gendry
how she could be gendry's family and at
the time Gendry still thinking himself a
lowly peasant now he's the second most
eligible bachelor in Westeros after Jon
Snow they have a moment to address that
tension and then I'll talk more about
Arya Gendry predictions through the
season because that's like a whole other
thing we could spend all day talking
about Aria and Gendry during the final
season and what will happen to them
after but after Arya initially
reconnects with Gendry then all the
Gendry associated characters start
showing up at Winterfell a couple of
them really big names on her list like
Melisandre and beric Dondarrion so
unless Melisandre beats beric back to
Winterfell because he's probably making
a beeline from the now destroyed wall at
East Watch with tormund pulling again
dree himself running faster than the
flash berrak would logically be the next
person that she crosses off just because
he's the first person that she comes
into proximity with after reconnecting
with Gendry if you don't remember why
Barrack is on arias list is because he's
the one that personally sold Gendry to
Melisandre and Melisandre is on arias
because she's the one that took Gendry
away in the only reason why Melisandre
is on the list is because she took
Gendry away she thought that she was
going to hurt him she doesn't know
anything about how bad it got with the
leeches and throwing him in the dungeon
at Dragonstone so imagine how Arya is
going to peel once Gendry tells her that
story unfortunately that's probably
something that's gonna happen off screen
there's a lot of Game of Thrones
conversations that happen off screen
where characters get caught up on
backstories like don't expect him to get
out a giant book and read it to Ori
about every little thing that happened
to him while he was away but mostly I
was rowing for a long long time then
eventually I went up at King's Landing
then a bunch of other stuff happened
then I wound up north of the wall now
you see me here and look who just showed
up Melisandre hopefully she did not
bring any more leeches with her so then
logically after Melisandre shows up she
would be the next one on the list but
because Melisandre is kind of important
to the fight with the knight King in the
army the dead she's supposed to be
bringing all these reinforcements the
fiery hand hopefully and maybe the high
priestess or some other red priest to
help fight the army it would be kind of
weird if Arya crossed her name off her
list before their big fight with the
White Walkers but logically Arya crosses
off the Gendry associated people from
her list when she's in the north then
they sort of turned their attention
south I know there's a lot of questions
about when which big battle will take
place they're supposed to be a big
battle at King's Landing in a big battle
at Winterfell it is totally possible
that they pull a fast one on us and
there's a big battle at King's Landing
before the big battle at Winterfell and
Winterfell is the final battle but
practically think about it this way
Cersei is probably going to survive to
the end of the season so it would be
weird if they completely destroyed
King's Landing at the beginning of the
season because then what would happen to
Cersei how would she survive all that
for the last couple of episodes waiting
for everyone to then come back after
another big battle at Winterfell
the logistics just don't make quite as
much sense in terms of where characters
need to be by the end of the season so
we'll just keep that open to speculation
we'll start talking more about that when
we get official trailers but obviously
you save the literal and figurative
biggest characters for last to cross off
of arias list so like I said even though
ill and pain is a little higher on
Arya's list because he's the person that
literally killed Ned Stark I don't think
he's as important of a character to the
show Watchers as the mountain is so
that's why I think when she gets to
King's
landing Ilyn Payne is the first name she
crosses off her list in her sort of
gauntlet on her way to Queen Cersei then
you obviously have to kill the Queen's
champion on route to the Queen so that's
why the mountain would be the next
person on her list but here's the thing
about the cleganebowl prophecy recited
in that clip that I put at the beginning
of this very important line of dialogue
maybe if we run into him we can cross a
name off of our list together so that is
why I think that the Hound goes full
MORTAL KOMBAT Clegane on the mountain
but is not strong enough to defeat him
by himself almost dies in the attempt
and Arya helps him finish the job there
are only a couple of ways we know to
officially end the mountain one would be
to set him on fire and just watch him
burn to the ground two would be to run
him through or chop his head off because
in his current state I think that body
wounds will only just slow him down
so Arya needs to make like Thor an
infinity war against Thanos
and go for the head that's the only way
to get rid of the mountain for good but
next early prediction the Hound dies in
the attempt but bringing things around
full circle makes peace with himself and
with Arya and dies with them
acknowledging each other as friends with
a smile on his face so it's a happy
death he goes willingly there not much
for words so I'm not expecting something
long drawn-out conversation where they
get all weepy with each other just like
a really nice moment where they nod at
each other
he smiles then dies and it's just a way
to acknowledge their arc like okay I
used to be a terrible person you used to
hate me for all the things that I was
doing you've also done some terrible
things now we're writing some of our
wrongs and we die heroes so it's
important to remember consequences it's
not like they're letting the Hound off
scot-free if he dies a happy man having
fulfilled his purpose of getting rid of
his brother in made nice with Arya
he still has to die in the same thing is
true for Arya Stark as well remember
what jaqen H'ghar told her when she left
the house of black and white
he gave her a second chance when she was
blinded for killing Meryn Trant when she
wasn't supposed to he then repeated
later a girl will not get a second
chance and technically if you're a
faceless person there is no quitting you
don't get to just walk out one day and
say I'm done there's still rules in a
code that you have to follow so I know a
lot of people are wondering if Jack and
Hegar is gonna come back but I'll
address that in a second when I talk
about obviously the last name most
important name on my list but then of
course Arya go
to cross Circe's name off of her list
last with a big surprise twist also
fulfilling valonqar with a little bit of
help from Jaime Lannister who he himself
has already Babe Ruth style called his
own death dying in the arms of someone
he loves so early prediction for Jaime
he dies in Brienne's arms earlier Arya
steals his face to get close to Cersei
in the scene of Arya crossing Circe's
name off of her list becomes a twist on
the scene of Jaime becoming the
Kingslayer with Arya killing the Mad
Queen so you get your valonqar and you
get arya crossing her name off of her
list at the same time in the finale and
it becomes this really big payoff for
the audience but because Cersei wasn't
named by another person Arya named her
herself it doesn't work that way if
they're gonna be true to the story the
greatest consequence to Arya given what
Maisie Williams has been posting on
social she says last woman standing she
was one of the last females to actually
film scenes for Game of Thrones so early
predictions she survives but the
greatest consequence they could deal her
is is that she loses the ability to see
permanently like she's permanently blind
henceforth although you know she did
pretty well on her own when she was
blind on the streets of Braavos so
considering all the terrible possible
things that could happen to you in Game
of Thrones
I don't do the going blind is that bad
let me know in the comments though what
are your predictions for how Arya
crosses those five final names off of
her list during season 8 we're probably
going to get that Game of Thrones Season
8 trailer in the next couple of weeks
with the true detective finale in the
Oscars because both of those things are
happening on the same Sunday night so
that's probably around when they're
dropping the Game of Thrones Season 8
trailer leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below
congratulations mudfish 24 you're the
giveaway winner for my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here for my new Game of Thrones season 8
episode 1 preview video
and click here for all my Game of
Thrones season 8 trailer and promo
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight